the jurogan experience yeah so if it's
vince had the original likeness and then
you know after a couple years i mean
it it had kind of taken over like i
lived that
like everywhere i went i was always
dressed in black
you know what people saw on tv they
pretty much saw in real life
so if you went out to dinner i wouldn't
dress quite that
quite like that but i would be an all
black
uh i didn't say much to people um
because you had to stay in character i
always stayed in character i always felt
like
i had i always felt like that i needed
to be what they saw on tv because if
they saw me
differently like if they saw this right
and then they see that on tv it's like
[ __ ] it's just acting it's just this
it's that
so i tried to make that guy real and i
did
for a long time like i didn't do for
years i didn't do interviews
i didn't do personal appearances you got
very little of me
other than what you saw on tv and that's
what kept people
captivated like i mean everybody [ __ ] i
know he's not dead
but but
he's [ __ ] up he's something's wrong
there's something right
and it captive you know to stay
and i'm not pat myself on the back but
to stay relevant for 30 years in this
industry
where there's so much exposure i mean
you have to i feel like that's the
extreme that i had to go to
um you know to to make that guy
continue to mean something does it feel
almost weird for you to be doing like a
podcast crazy
absolutely crazy so yeah it started
you know i i did a i did a docu-series
kind of
chronicling the the last few years of my
career
it was actually me trying to come to
grips with calling it a day really
it's called combine scooting this way
just into the microphone yeah better
there you go so we ended up calling it
it had nothing to do
with the jordan deal but it was called
the last ride which is one of my
finishing moves
so it kind of chronicled like the last
few years of my career and
and me kind of chasing the dragon for
that that one match that i could hang my
hat on and
say that's it that's it you know and it
and
as you get older and the injuries and
all that
i don't i don't i mean i i i figure that
in but i still see in my head
what i used to could do and that's what
i was striving
yeah i mean you've seen it in the fight
game yeah
all the time guys are looking for that
you know they can't come to grips with
the fact that their skills have
diminished
and there's a changing of the guard yeah
and
and it's kind of the same with with what
i was doing i was looking for that one
match that i could say
[ __ ] i still got it and now i'm
out was there
uh conversation about this with vince
where you were trying to figure out when
to close the door yeah there were there
was lots there were there were lots of
those conversations
and there were people that i talked to
along the way you know through my career
i was like look
if i get to a point where my skills have
diminished and i and i can't recognize
it
i want you to tell me or at least bring
the conversation up
you know and it got to the point where
nobody wants to have that conversation
yeah you know nobody wants to have that
like hey dude
your day yeah yeah it's up it's a real
i put a big burden on on people and you
know
they just couldn't do it and now vince
who i have a
unbelievable relationship with but uh
but also
that's a that's a huge intellectual
property for vince
30 years you know so he didn't you know
i could go out for another few years and
you know i could knock somebody on their
ass or i could
choke slam somebody but i can't do it
personally
right i can't because i know there's so
many guys that are coming up
that are trying to get that spot and you
know i can't go out there and
and okay i got all this equity built up
from all these years i'm just gonna
you know i'm gonna i'm just gonna live
off of that i remember when i was a kid
uh in boston they had uh it was a local
wrestling promotion but killer kowalski
killer kowalski was on
and i don't know how old he was at the
time but yeah
he had to be way way up in the
in the years i mean it looked like he
was in his 50s yeah and uh you know i
remember thinking like
even as a kid like how long can a guy do
this
yeah it and it varies who's the longest
are you the longest reigning guy
i think there's guys i think there's
guys that are like flare
lasted at at his level yeah he's the
longest by like a lot of he's he's
probably going to be humble about this
right now but even then the kowalskis
and all that the styles were different
right it was yeah
yeah and he's i mean he's throwing
people off of 16-foot
cells and getting thrown off of
titantron's like ramps and all this
crazy physical stuff it's a whole
different game and he went
10 15 years probably longer than most of
his peers well
the fact that i stayed 30 years with one
company
i think that's the one really big thing
is once i started with
with vince i stayed with vince where a
lot of guys you know they would
they would jump from one promotion to
the other and i stayed once i got there
i
i was there and you know wow it was uh
it's been a hell of a ride
30 years is a crazy ride so what was
your last match
my last match was in uh was april the
boneyard yes
april april 22. right here it is
it's a nice spike yeah that was uh
that's a
west coast chopper right there um
that's the bike actually belonged to uh
garth brooks
security guy but uh this
this was this was we got lucky because
kovit had already
shut everything down so everybody else
this is wrestlemania
so everybody else is doing their matches
in an empty warehouse
and we got to go off and and do this uh
kind of themed match they turned this
whole area into like a cemetery and
uh got to do a lot of theatrical stuff
and
so that must have felt like i could hang
my hat on this one
yeah you know we started filming that
about eight o'clock at night and we
wrapped at about five in the morning
and like at the end of it i was like
i can hardly stand up you know
everything was just locked up and i was
you know because i went into it you know
i started training for mania and
obviously i thought i was going to be in
a stadium in a ring
and uh i so i had really got a good head
start on my training and
you know my weight was coming down
everything was was good and then [ __ ]
covet hit
and then it was just like the gyms shut
down and then
you know then i got to you know i had to
get to florida
just to make sure you know that i was in
florida
right yeah because you never knew like
when they were going to shut all the
airlines down
so the training you know my training
kind of went to [ __ ]
and uh but i was really happy with how
this turned out
and i knew at the end of it physically
your day's done man
and you know as much as i want to do it
here and i want to do it here
it's just the body just it can't deliver
so what do you do now
i mean that's a long career i mean
yeah it is and i'm trying to figure that
part out
uh because i've dedicated my whole life
to this
to this business and you know i'm there
there'll be times you know i help out
and maybe mentor some guys but you know
i i haven't i've got to find out what
i'm passionate about
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch
back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience